okay um
for those joining this livestream we are
talking about neural nets for version 12
of often language and we are hopefully
at the late stages of dealing with this
particular set of documentation and
functions now apparently if this is
always a bad sign when it says some
design and consistency okay so what is
this about here so Stephen you see what
we have basically this text image cases
functions and text image contents and
more like fixing the notes we realize
that maybe it's a bad thing that we had
the cases family that have input and
then the rule syntax while the contents
family have the three argument fault it
may be needlessly confusing yes so we're
just looking for like some input each
other in any preference well I mean the
contents family is new right yes the
text case is actually is the only
documented function not text cases text
contents is also new in 12 but the
I mean in general the rule thing is more
flexible because it means you can
extract different properties for
different forms which is actually not
true for tax cases because it only
supports one rule and it's completely
it's basically always a full matrix
by the way this should probably be
renamed just if we're gonna do that
linkage they're listening of text
content types then this should be
renamed text content types that guide
page um in fact when in doubt just do it
yourself
you
you
okay by the way for those keeping track
this is the 200th live-streamed software
design review that I have done and we
will also be during this we're almost at
250 hours of a live streamed content
that's exciting one of those fine
tweetable events so that means I have to
take five minutes and make a tweet
sometime soon um okay back to this so
what you're telling me is that the the
the text cases family is there an
inconsistency with the way that text
cases works right now I mean on its own
it's it's it's doing its thing and it's
similar to cases that you have the first
argument as what you are looking into
and the second argument as what do you
want what do you want to do with it
basically right so okay so what is the
argument against contents working
exactly the same way as cases I've no
idea actually not sure why we started
with the three arguments formed of
contents yeah and we probably need
Jerome or a TN or both of them for this
discussion sorry Julian I just last
minute this morning found out this
inconsistency and wrote it down I think
that it was because text content was I
mean it began as a 1 argument function
then it became two arguments yeah and
three arguments like one after the other
so we never had a final look at the
design we just incrementally tweaked it
I would suspect we should just go forms
our props here um and we can always you
know that can always be supported in the
future but not documented if it turns
out there was a reason to go with the
third argument so we can change our
hands backward compatibility compatibly
this was never this hasn't been released
uh so there's no issue here yeah but so
why don't you um I took two to draw
myself okay okay let's go back to what
you mainly want to talk about here okay
this was I mean what was this about
properly arrow annotation we were just
going over stuff about entity value very
painfully by the way I should say Oh II
just we were looking at other functions
having the same structure and we found
the entity value that was it's not about
you know currently it supports property
Carmyle notation the three art form in a
sense okay communicate that to Tony
because we just had a big messy
discussion about um about entity value
okay um and another thing that was
bothering written also Jerome is that
for example for image identify we have
this syntax which is input category
comma n comma prop so basically if you
won't specify the property you have to
go down to the fourth argument identify
is new it has just been model after
image identify but imagine if I has been
out for a while yes I mean I agree that
is annoying to go to specify like for
example old comma old comma or old comma
1 comma prompt if you were so what are
you proposing proposing we say all arrow
probabilities that that we could back
port the the rules impacts and still
support a fourth argument formed from
backward compatibility but but suppose
the rule syntax for in magenta five as
well I don't think that's silly I think
it's a decent idea great and another
small thing is that we have this n
argument and we also have an option
which is called either max items Oh max
features I remember
two of them and that could in principle
be used in place of the end argument
freeing up an argument not just here
like in more places
the the issue that Jerome was pointing
out with this solution is that basically
we have that an automatic as an argument
gives you only one object without
wrapping it in a list and it clearly is
usually pretty adamant in having not
having options changing the structure of
the result it was basically if you do if
you do you specify any number for M it
will always be a list of results maybe
one maybe ten whatever but having an
automatic will can give you like just
one result similar to not giving
anything every similar to random real mm
something or random via something comma
one
yeah I know right
so I I don't know I I agree with both
things that is it's annoying to have
just in in this kind of feature
extraction function to use one argument
form the number of results but is also
consistent with the design in other
places I want to show there's people on
the livestream they're asking about data
extraction we could just show that's
what happens if we say text cases and
then we say date arrow interpretation
right it should be like the idea but
this will be able to get the data object
just doing date no the date just just
giving date will give the string its
string yes you're right
forget the extracted string let's see
does okay meanwhile um what is this
level thing LEM is largely different
from what you are looking for in a sense
because it's you say at what at what
level you want to look in a sense that
is like a block of text a line of text
word or or characters so it's a semantic
it's a structural thing basically that's
similar to their structural forms in
text cases we have word sentence
diagrams by the way for people on the
live stream isn't that spectacular that
we can take the Wikipedia article for
Chicago this is all new code the new
text cases is vastly stronger and yes we
will fix this thing about granularity
century and decade granularity there um
I'm curious if the it is impressive but
I'm curious if that if most of those
dates weren't already links in the non
pure text version no they weren't links
well sorry well let's see what if the
such chiliedu can't see interpretation
huh sorry
that didn't work
tray I dropped it in I'm curious if that
does work it would be even worse if that
didn't yeah yeah but that's a good
linguistic actually the 12th of August
in 2015 it's probably a linguistic that
may or may not have been because because
most of our date linguistics have been
for for often alpha queries that
particular type of thing which appears
in text is less some is less common and
that should be reported to the sushma if
you could report that to the the guys
dealing with that the project between
Allen and Etienne and so on um okay what
is this now
that I think I sold out with Jerome just
shortly before this meeting we were like
thinking about how how you can get more
nested categories but actually people
never notice that the index case is you
can use a function it's in place of the
property and you can use for example
Kiki take and and get so some
Association instead of the values and
have a most tracking result I think that
that covers at that point on emotion is
is very well documented but we cannot
examples with that right so livestream
is asking about the custom image cases
for image cases so I believe I mean what
what are we going to support in 12 image
cases does not yet have image patterns
right no I'm not image patterns but we
can provide networked packaging this
this region or so basically when that is
not what image analysis does do is it
provides something to make um
if we go to image cases it's dealing
with you you have now got the full
training for multiple you need to get
the CBS version okay
why is that saying bird speech
vacation that's entity formatting but
why is that
so what you're saying is women
you're saying okay that's getting all
cats in that picture right yep okay so
if I get and by the way whatever
happened to getting animals as a
category did we get that as a
recognition class I have to looking the
you have to look in the parser but I
won't have to push a better version of
the process soon so I just I just made a
note okay because and by the way the
interpreter we also need an animal's
interpreter and right now um you know
like random entity should be able to
give you a random animal not just two
random species which is mostly protozoa
that's a separate discussion I think um
okay great quack quack but that if I say
just Birds if I say bird they're okay
it's going to give the right thing and
if I were to say animal laugh
it's confused yeah because not all then
we basically the way I'm building the
parser here is is by reversing the
content of all the concepts entities
that are in the ontology so these
concepts they have like equivalent
entities or like common names so if
something is there we didn't want to
duplicate the like or to do any an
equation almost sounds like on top of
the entity so we are trying to fix the
entities and finding consistencies so I
I have to see why this animal string is
not there or if it is present in any
entity okay so what happens if I do this
if I say in which case I just pulled
this random image off the web image
cases of that comma tree no I didn't
think I didn't think I don't think it
will have tree yeah because the this
current network is is much smaller than
the one I'm training I wanted to demo
you in a better network but actually the
accuracy is to no yet so I'm still how
many categories is just I'm gonna have
the the one I'm training training to
actually one is having like the same
category amplify and and one that I'm
using to check what's wrong with the
accuracy is is having in almost 1000
okay so show for example here can I do I
have any hope of picking out those
creatures with the one with the with
both I guess
yes we will get animals and right now I
can't do it oh no no right now no is
nothing to build okay um so if I say I
just want to try something real here if
I say bird flock I'm just finding an
image of something okay
let's be
I'm very impressed if this works oh why
is it refusing to give me the image come
on
alpha goodness sake okay let's see this
is both easy and hard this case okay so
image cases of that comma bird from roll
oh my gosh yeah it doesn't get old here
what this is how cool some of the stuff
is that is cool okay so now let's say I
want to find the positions of those
birds so now I say image you can either
do image position initial position of
that or bird arrow position modifying
the previous input okay so you say image
position oops why is my yeah you don't
need to shout
it's okay so it's subpixels because it's
averaging things yeah it's the center of
the bounding box I thought I could I
could round it some less like some less
some of the opposition but I might image
so it didn't get all the birds how do I
do that if I say if i take this and i
say highlight image i like image the
image and and then you can copy directly
that the input is a second argument okay
only one blood mist pretty good jocular
do we have planners yeah I was thinking
about that getting the moon okay
I mean obviously this was a simple
background but but it's still very
impressive okay so get us our 10,000
classes and we'll be thrilled
yeah we should all something in magenta
fire to get more classes then how do you
mean what do you mean it doesn't add
10,000 classes in magenta fine now
it's like five or something you have to
check we have like three four thousand
leaves and then plus higher order
categories Simba's time do you remember
how many leaves do we have you know it's
two thousand two hundred or something
um let's just try one more just to see
what Tim was of this data sent that
Julio's got not as velocity vastly
larger than what this network was
trained under okay so when are we gonna
see this new training oh when well
enough that was not very impressed
No so with that complicated background
also that you have way less features
they are all black in the world the
previous image they had the internal
structure okay okay
so Steven a part of this meeting was to
make sure you see you go through the
five pages five six pages one last time
the one Sushma is listed we get the
pages on future eyes and then the
training network we expect to you know
we should have it before what is this
extract layer stuff and so on it's not
something straightforward I mean we
think so the thing to keep in mind is
that so this is really just the pre net
function version of extract right it
does it has the same semantics as
extract so you know that ideally this
layer wouldn't exist that we just have
extract so I don't I don't think it's
worth writing too much about anything
yeah I mean the design is
straightforward and we're confident in
the design but it also won't last long
but we do need it right away
otherwise we would have worked we would
have waited and told that function
you
this is an obscure object I mean you're
saying the input specifies
whatever I'm not thrilled about it
and your argument of it won't last long
is never famous last words I mean
honestly I don't actually follow like if
we weren't in a net functional world I
would defend extract there is perfectly
reasonable I don't know why you not
happy with it it just looks I mean it's
just kind of complicated okay
watering liar
what you copied this from somewhere else
from ordering yeah look look look read
what you wrote it's it can't possibly be
right represents an ordering net layout
that takes an input list this is
incorrect so yeah we should fix us yeah
this is just nonsense if I might say so
and do you intend these arguments to be
there yes
document says copying what ordering does
okay well okay you need to rewrite this
I mean do you want me to try to do it or
you nicely convert form that what is the
closest thing to ordering layer that we
have right now ordering okay and is this
knitted onto the onto the neuron that's
page we have on the guide page I'm
pretty sure I did that let's take a look
yes you do have ordering layer here and
you have extract layout you have
transpose layer so let's look
okay
okay
so
you
let's see represents a net layer that
gives what do you want to say here that
gives gives though it yields the the
ordering of the elements and the input
in the in the input vector it is
provided something like that because the
furnace copied from ordering I know but
it's not right because ordering takes an
explicit argument but this does not
right so read what this says represents
a net that transposes the first two
levels right so this is represents a net
why does this a net this should say at
layer unless we're not doing that for
most of these other ones I transfer
what's that yeah exactly
okay um okay represents a net layer that
gives the positions
well gives the positions in its input at
which what the heck do we want to say
here that takes that well that gives is
it true that it gives ordering of we can
use the word effectively as a kind of
hedge here because it really this is
don't work game play them what you want
to say that effectively gives ordering
of its input in other words this says
that Allah gives the ordering that gives
the ordering of its input ordering the
input ordering is a bit obscure like if
there's a you know if it says it
computes the equivalent of ordering
juice okay but gives the but effectively
gives applies ordering yes to it which
it which is a vector that's another
important thing well okay so then what
is this one
which effectively that that effectively
effectively applies ordering of an
because about ordering is as courier
ball it's not I'm sure it's not because
um ordering I think supports a vector
second argument so it will be ambiguous
but even if it is even if it died
doesn't motivate a second argument this
is horrible right now
terrible yeah
of Lee
well
um well it just gives the first n
elements doesn't it
the smallest in the positions of the
smallest in elements essentially Sam is
saying applies ordering hash end right
is it the same as saying take of the
result of ordering comma n yes
okay gives the first n elements
um
[Music]
in the ordering of its input a little
bit an elegant is this function also
going to go away when we get net
function this layer yes and that's you
see why we need to throw this direction
is that we can't add the whole language
to don't know this is completely crazy
yeah
all right well fine I mean I think
that's probably good it's pretty
horrifying but it's probably good enough
yeah okay okay let's go back over here
um okay what else do we have to figure
out you want me to look at the image
cases pages yes
you
you
okay gives an association of Subba
bridges for each
Wow there's a there's a one argument
form of image cases you suggested that
yes all is good ok so there's nothing
and not a match that's kind of
disappointing but with this with these
random geese or whatever they are you're
telling me that I should get you do
exactly the same thing
now you get a different you busy and you
get the equivalent to to put him bird in
a list because that's a category that's
a bird category as opposed to the
previous thing which was some kind of
bird entity class no no what is the
burden to class up up in the original
thing where you had this bird if I do
control equals bird right I'll get this
bird by default look at the bird species
specification that concept entities are
not discoverable but they are the output
of the image in different ology by all
the seven okay so wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait but how do they do they
have to become discoverable to be used
here don't they you don't have been you
force you can use them in inputs but the
point is that you don't have to use them
in input it you can use either
okay but that mean given that we didn't
have enough flexibility at the time with
entities I don't know interest in the
case we had this whole new concept thing
that we are carrying along
and uh it is the language of the
ontology now busy I understand it so are
we merging the the concept entities with
the other entities or how's that not
every concept as they I understand it
has a as another kind of entity but what
is there a plan for what to do with all
of that no I think we should when we're
out of the version 12 thing we should
meet and talk about that so if you can
get that scheduled it'll be a
complicated discussion yeah exactly the
one the one argument case should it be
returning an empty list that should not
return an empty Association and that in
that image did Stephen tried
the other harder yeah that one yes I
would think so why would it be an empty
list here yes actually I am is that that
case that's correct
Thanks one thing that I mean I didn't
put in the page because I a I know this
talking drum one hour ago is that we
should probably add the the functional
property here as well but okay if you
want to read the patron when we reach
that they can tell you okay
you
what does this mean
I understand this last one it says if
you want to search for birds and cats
you get an association that says bird
goes to sub-images cat goes to southern
but the way you're saying this gives an
association
but but and then there's also the case
category I arrow prop right the list of
categories arrow prop crap okay
you
well okay so this is an association of I
think category one the list category 1
category 2 should just show up in that
first table
mmm hold on because the list of sub
images identified as an instance
okay gives the specified property for
each identified some how much fine
okay now here
okay
you
this is saying that if you give multiple
categories here gives an association
with lists of sub images corresponding
to
identified as identified as being or we
could limit the first identified as
being
instances of the of each of the category
I is that right yeah
of each of category I yes that's correct
okay
you
what does this when attempts to finance
category present an image isn't that
what this just said
yeah Roger typically prefers we have a
descriptive note on top rather than
jumping to the tables and details well I
don't think it helps to repeat what
attempts to find instances of an object
category
well it's okay doesn't hurt nothing
you
how can this possibly work basically we
have if you take movies useful to do
this if you take one of those output
concept and you do a property
Association of it basically you you see
how this parsing is generated it's all
those all those things and we use as
input
um
I am really behind with meetings today
this is crazy this is just a minute I'm
just trying to figure out what's going
on here how much longer do you think we
have here um go through this one page
yeah all the other pages are copy paste
yeah we can
young terminal tables so if you happy
with this that's enough okay
sorry let's properly prop can be
you
okay okay one thing I would like to add
to this is to support a function
property to do the same as what text
cases is doing I don't know how I missed
that but I think it's been what does tax
cases to basically is when you have this
prop you can use a function this
function f at my apt to the Association
containing all properties I think this
is also answer my my issues about
formatting the result
okay all right looks good are these
pages knitted by the way
I don't think they are knitted very
properly I have some tentative
placeholders here and there I'll look at
all over
you know the first note is what we have
now discussed so they just fix it
you
you
this looks reasonable could you change
this to any of the phone I hate one of
the following since it's a just dumb
sure
what is this is that because it's using
your on that yes
you
looking good okay much contains cue
so I assume that this points to oh come
now come on you're pointless to to text
contents presumably as well and what
about to image recognize to text
recognize
speech recognising me projects
recognized yeah thanks recognized for
sure
fine faces definitely the special
features is it facial features rather
than fine faces this one is facial
features isn't it yeah these this finds
where things are by default but you can
use also to compute properties we have a
full list image identify and we were
like you create this looking at that
before we should probably use that as a
template for all these functions
this should also talk about presumably
text cases yeah yeah and we actually we
have an updated to see also saw like
like okay all right fine
image contains cue
you
you
is found an image is detected an image
if instances if at least one instance is
that right if at least one instance you
know the at least one is the one for the
input below the least one is that you
want to order now that at least one
instance of all of the colors one is
this one of yeah
at least one instance of each of the
category I
detected
you
okay
so the last one should be at least an
instance of at least one category of
contains
Oh
um
you
no that's okay isn't it
you
image position don't forget to point
that he do to pilot image well done yes
you
you
you
as instances of the specified category I
think it should say well which we say
pixel positions are they pixel positions
yes
image positions rather yeah if you see
position
yeah you need to go to say what kind of
XY positions they are yeah it says it's
the first this is I can know that the
coordinate system
all right okay okay looks good and image
bounding box I thought you had a
reference somewhere here to image
bounding boxes no okay much peddling
block sites we had image positions and
image bounding boxes and then you say
that what should it be cool what does it
no pounding boxes it is and I'll yeah
we'll have to fix that
see also also I think Julia a quick pass
on those illustrations I think we can do
better than just a coordinate system for
these guys no no yeah isn't there a
thing for bounding boxes for isn't there
another bounding box this function what
is it called boxes bounding regions you
meet the thing that gives coordinate
bounding boxes bounding region Oh
contents bounding box
what is that there's no any idea
bounding region that's probably
something for visualization or graphics
all this text bounding box
why does this not have any of its
documentation and so on because you're
dressed
by the way this spacing is just not
right look at what happens here there's
more space there than there is between
it between the sub pieces I think that
these sub pieces should have some kind
of grey line between them I think this
is unreadable Sushma's that's for you to
present back to the information slash
design folk
okay so is coordinate bounding box
consistent with image bounding boxes
in other words if I say coordinate
bounding box of image bounding boxes I
should get back the bounding box around
all of those little pieces of images I
mean you already get the bounding box
with the image bounding boxes no no no I
mean I mean that the a bucket of image
bounding boxes fed to coordinate
bounding boxes should give me
essentially the convex hull like
exterior bounding box awarding box does
not take rectangles in me retaining your
list of rectangle objects
um I'm guessing if you do bounding
region of those bound of those
rectangles I don't think it works now
but that's what should work um sorry
sorry lost concentration for just a
second could you say that again please
I'm sorry would you just say I'm saying
bounding region should work with a bunch
of rectangles but I don't think
coordinate bounding box okay no that one
I guess coordinate bounding box is
different as it takes coordinates but
bounding region which probably should be
mentioned here um oops
okay so gives an association of bounding
boxes
of image position bounding boxes is that
what it is
or are they rectangles no they are
rectangles yes then let's say bounding
box rectangles
or something rectangular bounding boxes
bounding box I think yes no we're saying
the first note that these things are
coming back as rectangle objects okay
gives an association what do we say
because what we want to say here gives
an association how do we do this for
image cases we just had a reasonable way
to say it
no it should say gives an association of
lists of sub images right
yes
you
okay
you
okay looks good all right can we declare
victory here I guess so yeah excellent
oh there's knitting though that you said
that hadn't been done
I can take care of that are you sure
okay I would like to see it actually um
um you just try sending it to me and
I'll send you a list of guides that they
touch
for this okay okay sounds good okay
thanks okay okay see you and people on
the live stream we are starting another
live stream quite soon I'm on a
different topic
Oh on Unity game engine interfaces okay
talk to you soon bye